alright stomm and Jen reporting in from
the apocalypse and progress it's
Thursday Thursday sitting around
watching YouTube what you've been doing
you've been working on stuff yeah I put
up the witching hour show earlier today
which has some two stories about stolen
bodies or out-of-body experiences I
guess one of them was HG Wells okay and
then I've just been working on a game
that I'm trying to get finished and
listening to mr. nightmare yeah creepy
stories I've been studying what's been
going on in the entertainment industry
for I guess many months now and I'm just
you know this has now been announced
that AMC Theatres ain't coming back and
there's a couple of other ones they're
not coming back
the theaters if you ask me are gonna go
the way drive-ins there might be a
couple of them but they'll just be
novelties maybe something in downtown
New York maybe in other countries like
China where people don't have bad ass
[ __ ] Smart TVs and surround sound and
streaming yeah but EMC was five billion
dollars in debt it been going on for a
long time and Corona pushed it over the
edge it's just you know there's some
people holding out thinking oh no maybe
somebody will buy it another company
bought it it'll be all right you're
[ __ ] tripping no the the theater game
I was looking at the numbers the theater
game is a losing man's game whoever buys
that will just lose their money
the it'd be like reinvesting in [ __ ]
drive-ins it's just an obsolete format
it's uh I think a lot of people have a
nostalgia for it you know the the cinema
and the theater but you got to go back
in history to see why they existed in
the first place they existed because
there were no TVs when TV came about it
actually
kind of put a little bit of hurt on the
movie industry back in the suit back in
the 30s and the 40s and the 50s you know
the during this during the silver screen
age everybody went there were lots of
theaters and people went many times a
week to see because there's no TVs TV
happened and then video rental happened
and now streaming has happened with it
on an HDTV it looks looks just as good
as stem Lake all the [ __ ] Dolby theater
it looks just as good as you know it's
gonna be even better eventually
you won't even need that damn TV set
it'll just be a pair of VR goggles that
you put on and headphones and you'll be
in the best movie of your [ __ ] life
looking around in every direction then
you'd be playing your video games in
that same format eventually it'll go
that way but if I was a betting man I'd
say movie theaters are gone well I feel
like it might go the way that a lot of
other things have gone where there might
be some open but they'll be very nice
very nice I think it'll be kind of like
I mean I don't think the multiplex can
survive because those the the profit
margin on though is much like
restaurants is very very very thin yeah
you know because they have to pay so
much for the movie rights they have to
pay so much for the equipment and like
the theater maintaining the theater and
stuff because it's so large let me stop
you for a second not only is the profit
margin thin it's not existence they're
all running in the red well I'm just
saying even in the best of times yeah
not like a it's not a high profit yes
it's you'll lose your money right now
AMC which is like one of the biggest
ones what's the other one that one's
closed to and probably will not reopen I
mean there's a whole bunch of different
ones bunch of I am he's the biggest one
I can't remember what the AMC is no
second biggest one is AMC's filing for
bankruptcy some people hoping well maybe
Disney will buy it they won't buy they
don't have the money if anybody were to
buy it it would be maybe like Amazon but
why would Amazon flush money down the
toilet that's that's going that's not
gonna last long and we'll the name
recognition no they don't give a [ __ ]
about name
recognition they care about money and
the future is streaming in very high
quality large Smart TVs that through you
can put an Xbox on you can [ __ ] have
Netflix you can if AMC survives it will
be a [ __ ] app you don't I mean or it
will be a service like Netflix where you
can watch brand-new movies for four of
them a week for $20 a month which is the
a-list program yeah you could do that
and if you got rid all that
brick-and-mortar [ __ ] you would start
making money yeah now here's the thing
people say well that's terrible
rich people have had that for a [ __ ]
decade yeah I've seen mansions that had
AMC Theaters in on the grounds of the
damn mansions maybe it'll seat 50 people
but that was an AMC theater and it was
streaming those movies whatever the guy
wanted so now it's been democratized
even poor people to have that yeah watch
Iran we don't have a really good set up
like that guy had but well they use
those he might have had a 10 foot screen
yeah okay but and it's in a pretty room
you know I mean but the average person
will just have like a four foot five
foot screen you know there's the really
big super a big big Smart TVs you know
that we have in Sam's they're nowhere
near as expensive as they used to be
yeah they're like 400 bucks fine well
everything comes down in price I mean
that I remember when VCRs first came out
they were like a thousand bucks
yeah or more well in a few years we'll
be able to afford a [ __ ] TV the size
of our king-sized bed cover up that
whole [ __ ] wall prob about 500 600
bucks yeah you know and then the sound
system I have is a good one but they
make even better once now like badass
once with fine that one wasn't even all
that expand that one wasn't even that
expensive its kind of old but if that
that sucker will blow you out of the
damn room you turn it up all the way
yeah I know I can hear it all the way
across house yeah it's not that loud
yeah so it's just changing the format
now that's really gonna [ __ ] up the
studios because the studio is really a
lot of those studios didn't have an
arrangements with Netflix and streaming
server
they had their arrangements with these
brick-and-mortar theaters all that
shit's got change all the era of
$150,000,000 advertising campaigns for
movies all that shit's gone that
industry what they're doing right now I
guarantee you the studios and the
theaters they're trying to downsize and
rehash and [ __ ] rebuild those
businesses they're gonna be streaming
well it really is kind of crazy to think
that you know Netflix for example a
service that started as you know movies
through the mail like DVDs through the
mail like back in the [ __ ] 90s or
early 2000s whenever it started that
that is now like the thing that
everybody watches and not only that but
they make enough money to fund [ __ ] tons
of their own content yeah that they're
putting in there when Netflix first
appeared it was just some kind of wacky
[ __ ] service you know I mean where
you could let's just you need the people
thought it would never second joke you
know I mean if you had told me at that
time this will get rid of Blockbuster
Video I'd bet manufacture it because I
grew up with blockbuster noise video
rental stores
well yeah you thought it was gonna I
thought that was last forever yeah no I
mean you thought that like the format's
would get better because right yeah like
I was right or blu-ray yeah and then you
know the idea of streaming it directly
to your house you know I mean I started
to become dimly aware that maybe that's
possible yeah not I mean because you'd
see porn or bits of movies you know I
mean from the clips of it on the
internet going back into the 90s yeah
you could kind of imagine that maybe
you'd be able to watch a movie over it
and what was it blockbuster tried to do
that back then they did I lost her ass
though well it's once they saw that
Netflix that Netflix model of like [ __ ]
through the mail because I think they
were one of the companies that were like
yeah that shit's not gonna work but then
when they saw that it was working then
they were like well [ __ ] now we have to
do that too but by the time they started
it Netflix had already taken taken up so
much of the market and had so much name
recognition that they couldn't really
compete with it yeah it's not you know
it's it's no one's fault really because
I feel like a lot of people you know you
can't really no one can predict
exactly what's gonna happen like I said
you know when Netflix first started
everyone thought it was a dumb idea
because they said holy [ __ ] you're
sending people DVDs through the mail
they're never gonna send that [ __ ] back
they're just gonna keep it they're gonna
do this and I thought DVD was worth 100
bucks
yeah and it's like and it's just funny
that like that didn't happen though you
know what I mean because they had like a
really easy setup it's like if you
didn't send the movie back you didn't
make your next one right they would just
charge it to your [ __ ] account and
then like they would just cancel your
account because they didn't know you
didn't send the movie back lately you
know this all explains the the the movie
studios the theaters they knew all knew
this was coming before we did they've
probably known for months all right
because these problems weren't caused by
the [ __ ] pandemic it was already
going bad the pandemic just pushed it
over the edge this kinda explains why
you have all these celebrities [ __ ]
go and crazy online and singing songs
their shits on the line they got to pay
these damn mortgages on all these
[ __ ] mansions and once this industry
downsize us they're not gonna be able to
afford all that [ __ ] the era of big
movie stars huge budget movies where
they're just [ __ ] doling out cash you
know here hunt up a 150 million to
promote my movie a lot of they had to do
the money laundering and [ __ ] crooked
[ __ ] - all that shit's gone the industry
just can't support that anymore
this concept like right now you could
see blood shot all over my xbox but they
want 20 bucks for that and I think it's
you have to make you buy it for 20 bucks
yeah but it's my understanding based on
what other people are saying nobody's
really watching it it's not making much
money because everybody's just gonna
wait a couple well you can regular rent
it for [ __ ] five bucks five bucks
yeah so this is why wouldn't you why
wouldn't you so these this industry at
that bad is gonna have to pull itself
out of its own [ __ ] you know I mean
it's all up inside of itself their
movies aren't worth that much to the
average person they need to directly put
them up for rent as soon as they're
[ __ ] ready that's the only way
something like AMC would ever survive
but I don't I think that technology is
so easy to do why would AMC
even bother with that yeah why would
people would just go out [ __ ] AMC I'll
just wait the extra couple weeks and
rent it so well I think people were
doing that and they were doing that
anyway
so this whole High Roller mentality all
the people in the media they're just
gonna have to adapt to a new reality
they're not worth what they thought they
were worth that's all it is
well they can you know I don't I don't
know how much like some of the streaming
services and stuff like that I mean I'm
sure like Disney has like [ __ ] tons of
money to produce original content and
[ __ ] like that but so we might be seeing
an era of like smaller budgeted moves
that's just that's good which is fine
with me a lot of times they're better
yeah not always but you know sometimes
they suck even worse but honestly you
don't need a lot of money if you you
know if if you don't have like a good
[ __ ] idea or a good script or good
actors or whatever then all the money in
the world isn't gonna make that a good
the movies of the future gonna be niche
marketed movies for certain audiences
and they're gonna be globe budget and
well done that's what those are the ones
that are gonna make a lot I said there
might still be movie theaters in the
sense of like like I said here in
Orlando we have the Enzian theater which
they just show like one like indie movie
or like a documentary something like
that and they have like a full little
restaurant like a cafe in there you can
things like that you can drink weird
beer and wine and stuff like that while
you're watching the movie and it's
really cool and like I said like an
event yeah like when I like when I was
um still lived in Daytona like this is
going back like 10 or 15 years ago there
used to be like this little bitty like
movie theater once a week they would
show it was either an indie movie a
documentary or like a foreign movie that
it kind of got a lot of buzz or whatever
and it was just like this tiny little
room it's just like they had all these
little chairs and stuff they had like a
tiny little cafe in the front where they
had like coffee and cookies and [ __ ]
like that and you just went it was like
five bucks or something and you just
went in there and watch the movie and I
used to go down there like all the time
yeah cuz you know it was it was [ __ ] up
I mean it was like the middle of the day
so it's like I worked at night so I
could go like I think that's the only I
think only two ends of the spectrum will
now survive you'll have these a high-end
theater that's expensive and it has like
artsy fartsy [ __ ] going on in it or and
if somewhere
New York and it's like big openings and
it costs a lot of money to go see it be
that or will be the other end of the
spectrum
it'll be these theaters some some poor
area in China where people don't have
funding Smart TVs yeah what I'm going
where they go and if you look at what
they're charging them in China they're
not charging them very much couple
dollars to see a movie yeah and they're
trying to get out of house anyway they
live in these little bitty apartments no
air conditioning so you know I make
sense in a market like that but in the
United States that no longer makes this
makes any sense when everybody has Smart
TVs and everybody has an internet
connection yeah I mean most people do
and it and it really does seem like I
mean like I was saying before we were
talking about this it does suck because
I actually did like you know going out
of the house going to see a movie um you
know what I mean just so I didn't have
to like sit which we kind of have to do
everything is coming to the house uber
eats everything is coming to the house
now that's the [ __ ] that's like
honestly you never have to leave the
house like depending on what your job is
I know something I will do but it's like
I mean I even before the pandemic
started it's like sometimes we would go
like a couple of weeks without really
leaving the house didn't really have to
other than you know we go into like the
groceries buys another liquor store but
we didn't really go yeah so some people
are freaking out we're like well it's
about the same for us it's about snot
yeah it's like not really it's like it
sucks that you know we can't go out
dancing obviously we can't go we can't
go out to like the Indian restaurant we
can they might be doing delivery I'm not
really sure but but you can't go eat in
there that kind of stuff will come back
though yeah so I so but other than that
like I've been working at home like I
said since 2016 so it hasn't really made
that much difference yeah um and a lot
of people who are working from home now
for the pandemic will always be working
from home
those companies ago you know why are we
rent in this office space well this [ __ ]
David downsize doesn't only keep people
that absolutely had to be on site yeah
the recipe and everybody else he worked
from home and they already have a
working relationship with them and they
can just replace them one by one as they
time out you know as they fire more
places so it's not a traumatic shift for
a lot of those companies
and you'll have a whole segment of the
workforce and it'll be white-collar jobs
they'd be working from home yeah because
I mean honestly a lot of jobs that I had
I didn't understand like you know I
returned
well yeah I didn't enter so it's like
why the [ __ ] do I have to be here I'm a
graphic designer
it's like you know send me just like I
do now like with freelance send me what
you want like through the [ __ ] email
and I'll do it and send it back to you
it's like why do I have to like
physically be in the office that came
from a 1950s yeah 1830s mentality where
you had to [ __ ] slave Drive people
you needed a supervisor to make sure
everyone was doing their work yeah which
if they're not doing a work [ __ ] a
firearm you don't need a supervisor well
and honestly I really go see office
spaces
everybody's seen off base but yeah
that's a cult classic yeah but um yeah I
was I was gonna say that it's like
honestly I think people are more
productive when you kind of put them in
charge of their own time or their own
scheduling most people are you know I
know that there are some people that
might need more structure and stuff yeah
it's like yeah you don't you know hire
them well if you give people time to
like [ __ ] around you know what I mean
and just like hey I'm gonna take like a
10 minute break and like you know you
know read something on the internet and
have a cup of coffee or something like
that you can do that whenever you want
to I think people you know I think they
work a lot better than if you be like
you know hovering over people it's you
have to do this right now and you to do
this right now it's like I never really
did very well in those types of
situations where I always had somebody
watching me or somebody telling me that
was a 19 that was it yeah that was an
1800 sweatshop model yeah and it's weird
because like I worked a few jobs that
were like that that like I said that
were it wasn't like a factory or
anything like that it was like you know
it was printing or publishing or
something like that that's what I've
been working you got one 90 days walking
around watch looking at everybody you
working that's what I mean and the guy
that was doing that I don't know how did
Danny this any of the [ __ ] that we were
doing so it's like why don't you just
let us handle that okay it's like you
know we don't really need you like yeah
babysitting or like hovering around
hey what are you doing hey what he does
like just quit breathing on me
you know my buddy who's into that damn
toy manufacturing business you know over
in Japan you know making all these
little Japanese things it's the same
with his industry all the little
middleman scam scammers and and all the
comic book shops and all the toy shops
of [ __ ] who are all adding money onto
top of that product all gone you don't
need that messed of method of
distribution anymore it's such a right
over you babe well like I you know it'll
work from a factory and I really liked
you know when we probably talked about
this before but I really liked when the
whole like you know self-publishing
thing kind of came into like a more
feasible type of thing and there's like
infrastructure now to do that because
now it's like I don't have to go through
like all of these you know jump through
all these hoops I can like write a book
design the book I can upload it and
people can read it if they want to read
it or listen to it if it's audiobook or
whatever so I can just do everything
myself and like just get everything to
people that might want it like directly
without having to worry about going
through yeah all kind of different like
steps in between yeah and then you
people worry you know what happens to
all the workers well a lot of [ __ ] went
to China when that stuff comes back
manufacturing might increase a lot of
people who have to physically work for a
living will just leave AMC Theatres and
go work somewhere else maybe making
inner tubes or some stupid [ __ ] like
that there's always a way Society will
adapt it might take some time but or
that person now is somebody who works
online something like that yeah there's
always gonna be weird imbalances there's
gonna be unemployment but they're also
going to be unemployment checks and [ __ ]
because yeah if you kind of look at
what's been going on in society it's
obvious that once they kind of sent
everything over to China the priority
became to reduce the United States
population the rich people created you
to be one of their farm workers or one
of their factory workers and when when
they gave that to China for liking they
decided to get rid of you or to put you
on welfare to buy a cheap Chinese item
that
they had their companies over there made
yeah it's all a scam it's all a scam
they'll figure it out
they'll figure out how to scam you again
actually don't worry they bent over
actually if you look at who's struggling
and who's [ __ ] getting wiped out
right now the weakest and the biggest of
the scams are going down though you know
and in entertainment was one of them as
kind of a [ __ ] scam I mean in a way
it depends on everything is kind of a
scam all businesses kind of are the
problem is all these little businesses
these little mom pop businesses nail
salons hair salons and [ __ ] like that
they're not getting any money right now
well yeah and there's you know what are
they the difference is is that a small
one man-to-man three-man operations can
make big comebacks quickly but those
huge empires like AMC they're [ __ ]
toast because the amount of money that
you need the amount of organizations
that you need yeah it says to
resuscitate that [ __ ] is in the [ __ ]
tens of billions of dollars that money
in there but you know you got a guy who
loses his shop and really all he needs
this five grand to start back up yeah
that's that's that's doable especially
if you have a landlord who's who's
hurting for money and he says I'll tell
you what I'll give you I'll give you you
know two free months just start your
business back up yeah I've heard a lot
of that kind of [ __ ] is go well [ __ ]
even might like our banks and credit
cards and stuff like that have all said
hey click here if you needed affirm it
because I know everybody's like yeah you
know doesn't have you got to pay it
later obviously but they're letting
people like so they're letting people
skate in my superior Thomas mind [ __ ]
superior my [ __ ] mind my [ __ ] mind
it's like a bad fish you go fast [ __ ] a
supercomputer okay
it is man I could [ __ ] I could see
how this [ __ ] going it's like in my
imagination it's a quantum super
computation going on okay I'm telling
you if yours if you're a small business
owner you're [ __ ] right now but when
it'll start back up you'll make a quick
comeback and you might have any
advantage because the
big guys won't be there they won't be
that's where it might open up some news
you know the market that weren't there
same thing the [ __ ] Black Death did
to the to the Middle Ages once it killed
off so much [ __ ] they had to free the
serfs yeah yeah because that was really
weird service labor was now worth
something no the only thing I mean you
had to pay me we're not saying it was a
good thing that happens like yeah fine
but it's like at least afterward it had
there was like a silver lining yeah this
is gonna open up new frontiers for
everybody this is this is shaking it up
shaking it up for some reason when you
said that I thought of like playing
Yahtzee and like taking the dice I was
thinking other cars shake you that was
another song that I used to [ __ ] who
was I talking to the other day about all
the songs we used to like roller skate -
I don't remember who I was talking to it
must been a while back still rock and
roll yeah
the one I remember the most is [ __ ]
centerfold but yeah geils bands all
those [ __ ] cheese yes and Jack and
Diane I remember like rollers guess she
was sexual that's super freak yeah that
was a little past might that way yeah I
guess it wasn't yeah I was like when I
was rollerskating when I was about nine
or so you Rick James yeah but yeah so uh
that all we have to say yeah Thursday
show today yeah just uh don't don't
listen to all this [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's out there and all this you know
positivity
now that's [ __ ] they're [ __ ] well I
mean you got a state you got to stay
positive just in your own things if
you're I should yeah I'll say you don't
go [ __ ] mental but it's like but I'm
talking about Hollywood [ __ ] movie
theaters studios they're [ __ ] even
[ __ ] Disney's [ __ ] does that Disney
streaming thing isn't doing well well
like close all the theme parks - yeah so
that's yeah and Disney actually it was
in bit of money Disney was not that
healthy it was well though they own
everything the sliding yeah Disney was
sliding their stock was sliding and you
know they [ __ ] up Star Wars and their
franchises aren't worth what they used
to be in the streaming thing isn't
working
same thing with CBS and the Star Trek
franchise there's a lot of stuff that's
[ __ ] it's time for a renewal we have
to rise from the ashes like a phoenix
and make new [ __ ] its renewal like
Logan's Run yeah hope maybe we don't
know [ __ ] blown up and guy get rid of
these old [ __ ] who were scamming
people
that's all [ __ ] scams the old way of
doing things [ __ ] gone it's going
back to the little guy kinda yeah I mean
I kind of hope it does good yes me
because we're the little guys yeah you
know well wait when I see big [ __ ]
movie stars and people like [ __ ] talk
show hosts trying to be youtubers I feel
good of like [ __ ] you try to be
a YouTube freak
that's [ __ ] that's a bad sign for
them that's a bad sign they know what
the future is though yeah we replaced TV
and the movies yeah I mean you know I
still watch movies and stuff but yeah I
just I do watch a lot of stuff on you
yeah a lot of you if you looked at hours
of hours of consumption YouTube kicks
ass over all that [ __ ]
I mean I've yeah I have like a lot of
shows that I really yeah YouTube and
Netflix kicking ass yeah yeah Netflix is
probably like yeah and show everybody we
love shudder - yeah we do love shudder
and I think there's just gonna be more
stuff like that now
AMC if it exists it will be something
like shedder yeah it might just become
the specialty app because yes they seem
like everything is kind of going that
way yeah a little specialty kind of but
I think what'll end up happening this is
this whole idea of the differentiating
between a new movie and a [ __ ] used
movie will vanish I think that's what
will happen the prices will all be the
same it's just you don't mean you don't
have movies than the movies a [ __ ]
movie if it's a new movie than
everybody's getting it it should be the
same price as the [ __ ] movie from
through this four weeks old this is no
[ __ ] difference they're just trying
to scam and you don't have to support
these big brick-and-mortar theaters
anymore it's just an electronic signal
they're [ __ ] sending you why is it
more the court you know why greed yeah
they're just trying but they're just
[ __ ] themselves because like I said
blood shot sitting right there for
$19.99 No
[ __ ] buying it you'd be an idiot well
because like I said just wait what we
went on there I mean even stuff that was
out as recently you know as birds of
prey or something like that that's
already only like five dollars to rent
so many people are saying it's like well
why don't I just wait wait two weeks
there are three weeks right and then
it'll be like you know a quarter of the
piss people see that 1999 he goes let
seeing it early I'll just wait till it
becomes a regular release at $5.99 and
then I'll see you know that's the
release date that's what I mean no one
wants to see it that [ __ ] yeah nobody
wants to see it early that bad alright
but yeah so um yes anyway everybody hang
in there I'm done being an [ __ ] I
don't think you are that's gonna be one
of the main attractions of the [ __ ]
sidetracked on video I mean they're not
done being a hassle on this particular
video like in life in general that's
like the main s my [ __ ] superpower
that's the main attraction to the side
track if you ask me you're giving it
she's gives the information you give us
straight I'm gonna be a [ __ ] about it
yeah absolutely it's kind of like it
it's kind of like a Dan Costello it's
kinda like salt and pepper it's kind of
like sweet sour okay that's what we
should call the show now sweet and sour
pork
it's pork alright weird you know we did
all kinds of sit-ups and [ __ ] well and
yes cut my [ __ ] caloric intake
yesterday we were very good we only had
to had some vegetables it's just salt
and pepper on there yet and then steamed
vegetables and then we just had what
we'll assume you have hardly anything
yeah a tad a protein bar yeah yeah today
we just had a pork chop in a little bit
of Spanish rice yeah that's all we bad
yeah that's probably all really yeah I
might have a protein bar later but
yeah alright I'm done entertainer you
done entertaining yeah you can go back
to sleep or whatever I say go go and
play with Pookie see wishes yes if
pogies [ __ ] sleep yeah cuz she was up
all night she sleeps like a person she
stretches out like a person laying in
bed yes she stresses it cuz she'd late
she sees us do it so she doesn't curl up
in a ball like cats she stretches out
like a person ever hand on the pillow
she got mad because she she went um she
was like short on treats you know what I
mean all the night and it was like four
times four or five in the morning she
goes she jumps up on the window like on
the sheets she says she hits the shades
against the window to wake him up cuz
it's like the windows like right next as
soon as I knew she was fire she runs she
knows I'm [ __ ] mad I get up yo [ __ ]
you do I look at her [ __ ] feed dish I
got a little dead dish next to the bed
it's empty yeah it's like wake up a
little temptations cat treats a [ __ ]
Kitty crack [ __ ] gears some Katy
crack thank you
man out here from the rez of the day mad
because you didn't give her an ugly one
okay yeah she just had to like beg
because she knows that's really loud
they say cats can't plan ahead it's
[ __ ] because if I go to sleep she'll
[ __ ] yell at me and make a noise and
point at that damn dish if it's empty
yeah give me some food what and I'll
pour it she won't eat any she'll save
for later yeah she's like I just wanted
to be like in case you were still gonna
sleep for several more hours well we
used to have the when we used to have
the shelves of like all the DVDs and
blu-rays in the bedroom now it's like
that in the walk-in closet
[ __ ] because what she would do is she
would jump up on the shelf and she
pulled them out with her hands yeah he's
just heard a little pot like a hand yeah
she'd [ __ ] grab from the tongue on
Archie and she'd throw them at the end
you know no monkey man I swear to God
yes she's like a tiny autumn oh never to
see the cat do that she picks up [ __ ] in
one hand and throws it late yeah she's
flinging it across the ring is this a
men thing if the toys smells like mint
and she picks it with one hand somehow I
don't know how there's then fingers
guess it's Claus she'll pick up one hand
and rub it on her face like it's a
washcloth like even on her neck instead
she's like
I gotta get a [ __ ] recording of that
but that's it I got a little bit of her
doing that I've never seen a cat act
like that she's super weird but adorable
she thinks she's got hands and shoes she
thinks she's a person
well yeah cuz she eats like that too
like she's just gonna eat it she scoops
her food off the plate and it's not full
time not all the time it's just when she
starts a lot of time she'll yeah she's
like she's it's very dainty then she'll
knock it off and then she'll pick it up
and knock it off oh yeah she's probably
sleeping yeah so uh everybody be safe
and healthy out there we'll talk to you
guys again tomorrow